[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette émission
on va parler de jazz et on va parler
d'un instrument
formidable dans le jazz sur lequel le
jazz n'existerait pas c'est la batterie
avec un des gros batteurs français David
pour habiller du tail bonjour bonjour
Patrice ça va bien ça va très très bien
grand batteur
d'abord vous habitez Coignières 1 m 70
1m70
mais vous habitez Coignières donc je
suis actif je suis un yvelinois pure
sucre et alors on va parler aussi du
trio que vous avez formé qui s'appelle
le Adrian Clark trio lequel vous tournez
beaucoup et parfois dans les Yvelines on
donnera quelques dates mais on va
commencer quand même par la batterie
comment comment devient batteur
justement comment comment la batterie
est entrée dans votre vie comme on dit
je
c'est tellement vieux que du coup je
c'est tellement ancré dans les
vraiment très très très petit on
habitait au Tremblay-sur-Mauldre donc
entre Montfort et Pontchartrain par
Montfort-l'Amaury Pontchartrain par là
et j'avais la j'ai la chance d'avoir un
frère pianiste oui et donc on avait un
piano à que à la maison d'accord et mon
père ramenait davait ramené des
percussions de il bossait en Afrique mon
papa il est architecte il avait ramené
des quantités et on les rangeait sous le
piano à queue
[Musique]
ces deux choses là n'ont jamais quitté
c'est une bonne remarque c'est-à-dire
que dans le jazz il y a effectivement
c'est le haut lieu de l'impro
d'improvisation sauf que moi bah au
niveau de l'énergie
j'adore ce qui est aussi ce qui
n'appartient pas spécialement au jazz et
ce qu'on a connu dans les années 70 la
pop on a appelé ça après le
progressivement etc et ça cette veine là
moi je l'adore du coup Led Zeppelin en
fait il y avait beaucoup d'impro mais on
a un peu oublié ce côté
comment dire pas débridé mais enfin
libéré voilà où ça jouait vraiment avec
beaucoup plus de de liberté on a
tendance à dire le jazz il y a un pro et
l'Europe
c'est plus cadré si vous prenez
l'autre jour avec un pierre en taille
qui est un grand claviciniste de musique
baroque de musique ancienne et il me
disait mais
cette époque là au 17e 18e siècle il y
avait pas de vrais concerts et c'était
souvent des improvisations
et même et même des grands musiciens
venaient
il jouait ce qu'ils avaient écrit la
veille il avait pas de programme de les
concerts aujourd'hui et je veux beaucoup
d'impôts ce qui est assez intéressant
parce que au fond les musiques se
rejoignent alors revenons quand même à
vous il y a des percussions
et mais la batterie que j'aime en fait
elle arrive quand c'est à dire que
j'avais un ami de mes parents qui qui
nous avait à l'époque fort bien aiguillé
et j'avais 11 ans donc j'étais tout
minot et il a dit bah il y a une super
école à Paris qui s'appelle l'école
Agostini et moi j'ai fait cette école
dans les grandes longueurs j'étais
vraiment tout petit et à 11 ans donc
c'était les années 74 15 et à cette
époque là dans les années 75 il y avait
pas de gamins qui qui de 11 ans qui qui
se mettait dans ces écoles là qui
s'inscrivait donc c'était
le ministre de service jusqu'à l'âge de
15 saisons et donc j'ai en grand j'ai
beaucoup de de technique
supérieur le premier alors Premier prix
Un premier Président
j'ai mis un petit peu de temps à l'avoir
parce que j'arrivais au bac quand même
temps ah oui donc c'était c'est un peu
embouteillage
ton bac d'abord
le fameuse phrase que j'ai appliqué et
puis en fait ça m'a ça m'a
clarifié l'esprit en fait le fait de
passer ce bac de mettre deux ans à la
voir d'ailleurs au lycée des 7 Mares à
Maurepas là juste à côté
de bac
c'est-à-dire que je l'ai raté quand même
peut-être qu'il a fallu je me suis pris
à deux fois non non mais en fait ça m'a
vraiment clarifié l'esprit j'ai senti
que c'était vraiment le il a fallu ça
pour pour
pour faire que de la musique en fait
vous avez fait une télé à 14 ans alors
oui c'était quoi ça
s'appelait c'était Roger Pierre
Roger Pierre raconte oui ça s'appelait
et en fait c'est un ami dans D'Agostini
le qui tenait l'école de batterie le
super prof super pédagogue qui a conçu
toute cette méthode vraiment que dont
beaucoup de de pédagogues de la batterie
se sont inspirés par la suite c'est lui
qui est un bon batteur qui est un super
batteur de revue
il a il a conçu de mettre un super
progressive pour la batterie et en fait
il m'avait il nous avait invité on était
on était cinq ados et on a fait plus lui
six on était 6 et on a joué un solo de
batterie en tout dis ce qu'on dit en
tout petit on était si batteur qui joue
la même chose pratiquement pendant
c'était très court ça faisait deux
minutes et j'ai jamais répété un truc
aussi un nombre de fois aussi important
j'ai compté le temps qu'on a pour deux
minutes de de on a on a dû répéter 24
heures en fait c'est deux minutes là
donc je suis arrivé là-bas à 14 ans 177
voilà donc c'est super expérience
dans le cinéma d'ailleurs enfin bon mais
enfin
pour parler de vous c'était quelqu'un de
curieux donc 16 ans vous avez le bac
2018 enfin j'ai eu mon prix de l'école
et vous vous dites il y a un moment où
vous dites je vais faire ça quoi en fait
physiquement il y a une espèce de déclic
quand j'étais au lycée comme je commence
j'adorais les oreilles adoré être
ornithologue je suis très attiré par par
les choses de la nature les oiseaux
particulièrement mais l'écologie en
général et puis bon je bien que il y
avait un petit quand même un petit souci
de compétence quand même
mais non mais
non non c'est vraiment j'avais déjà un
gros bagage technique en fait avec un
peu de de métier comme on dit par contre
de très peu de métiers je dirais il y
avait un gros un gros déséquilibre et en
fait ce qui m'a bizarrement c'était
c'est l'armée qui m'a je ne connaissais
personne maintenant ce métier voilà
c'est ça c'est un métier complètement
bizarre parce qu'on on sait pas comment
ça marche
et on sait pas comment comment on peut
atteindre des orchestres etc j'ai lu
quelque chose qui dit un batteur et
d'ailleurs j'ai trouvé ça intéressant on
dit comment comment on devient comment
il faut faire quand on est batailles dit
d'abord faut avoir une très bonne
technique instrumentale être à l'écoute
des autres et se construire un réseau
pour pouvoir entamer une éventuelle
derrière professionnelle c'est
exactement ça en fait j'ai découvert
cette notion de réseau un peu à
l'ancienne
complètement à l'ancienne c'est à dire
bah les gens
il faut être en situation d'être appelé
qui nous appelle ce sont les chefs
d'orchestreurs et les arrangeurs et les
horreurs voilà donc c'est eux qui c'est
eux qui ont le le qui qui ont besoin qui
ont besoin de nous éventuellement
quand vous avez joué avec un tel on vous
appelle etc bon moi j'étais pas j'étais
plutôt super vachement timide donc
j'étais pas j'allais pas trop à de
vendre des choses des gens donc j'étais
un peu en situation de d'être un peu
j'étais un peu passif donc il faut
peut-être avoir une attitude plus
peut-être
les acteurs c'est comme voilà tout une
série de ce qui était drôle à l'armée il
y avait un et alors à l'armée
je me suis inscrit à la j'ai postulé
pour être à la musique du régiment à
côté de Paris donc en fait je continue à
prendre mes cours de batterie et c'était
une super un super une super place quoi
et donc j'ai passé une audition etc pour
rentrer là c'était à Suresnes à musique
de
Valérien voilà et puis du coup et en
fait j'ai rencontré énormément de
musique
qui eux par contre ils avaient plein de
contacts du coup j'ai commencé à
comprendre un petit peu comment ce genre
de ouais parce que c'est vrai que si on
joue du piano on peut jouer seul
si on joue alors après la batterie
il faut qu'on soit plutôt avec quelqu'un
quoi alors ben non seulement il faut
être plutôt avec quelqu'un mais je
dirais que c'est le c'est la fonction
principale du batteur on en a parlé
juste avant que le début de l'émission
là de de des qualités on va parler ça
après des qualités du batteur mais c'est
vrai que voilà c'est un instrument qui
qui a besoin d'un orchestre absolument
c'est ouais ouais moi je sais c'est ma
grande mon grand je trouve c'est une
notion qui est passionnante de se mettre
de cet instrument c'est un instrument
qui fait d'air on doit on doit bien
c'est nous qui mettons en notre boulot
c'est de faire que les gens aillent bien
ensemble en fait c'est pour FEDER on a
un fédérateur on est on fait des choses
par contre on peut aussi très vite
casser un orchestre ah oui c'est en bas
contre toi surtout si on l'ajout perso
ah oui c'est pas trop le but quoi mais
le rythme par exemple le sens du rythme
ça s'apprend
où ça se c'est un don je pense que c'est
vraiment un truc de c'est c'est
on va je vais faire une analogie avec
les gens qui disent qu'il chante faux
ils sont persuadés qui chantent de fond
alors je dis pas que c'est faux ce
qu'ils disent par contre c'est comme
pour le rythme je moi je suis aussi
pédagogue j'adore je viens de repartir
sur une dynamique de données des cours
là d'accord et j'en suis j'en suis ravi
et je trouve que comme pour le chant
c'est le la clé de la musique du rythme
du chant etc
c'est l'oreille c'est ça ça par contre
ça par contre ça s'apprend de savoir
écouter vous savez écoutez écoutez les
autres écoute non mais c'est écoutez
écoutez ce qui se passe développer son
oreille en fait le travail d'oreille je
déplore je dis ça très humblement dans
les conservatoires il me semble que il y
en a mais j'ai pas l'impression que ça
soit je forme au niveau je formule le
veut que cette ce truc cette notion là
devrait être de beaucoup plus développée
je trouve je trouve que ça serait génial
parce que c'est la clé c'est voilà alors
donc vous dites pas rester écoute tout
seul quand même très longtemps mais oui
il y a eu des premiers voilà des
premiers contacts comment ça se fait les
premiers alors bah c'était c'est long
ouais c'est-à-dire qu'on a quelques
quelques dates comme ça alors j'ai fait
du jazz un peu le Bebop les choses comme
ça le mais j'étais pas dans les grands
trucs que j'étais pas je faisais très
peu de variétés
j'ai commencé plutôt par le jazz les les
les les on dit c'est un peu vieux comme
mot mais les combos trio quartet tout ça
alors je vois dans des clubs à Paris que
ça payait pas terrible je donnais des
cours bon c'est un ça c'est pas c'était
pas facile et puis petit à petit j'avais
plus on m'appelait petite de plus en
plus et puis ça a commencé après à
ça ça fait boule de neige mais c'est
long c'est assez long ouais bon après
[Musique]
et là et là le batteur il a eu besoin
tellement de de pousser de de
15 ou 16 17 musiciens
on n'est pas on n'est pas en trio
quartet là avec le grand et bien alors
ce qui était génial c'est que j'ai eu
trois remplacements de suite dans trois
contextes différents tout de suite pour
commencer donc trio
big band on était au Petit Journal
Montparnasse et
trio plus orchestre symphonique
pas mal alors ça c'était super
impressionnant
dans le pour lequel on se greffait donc
on arrivait avec les violences
qu'on se mettait au milieu de la nuit de
la scène et tout l'orchestre était là
c'est magnifique alors des musiciens qui
sont qui ont un niveau absolument
topissime et qui viennent vous voir en
disant c'est formidable ce que vous
faites non c'est pas formidable on fait
juste du jazz et c'est des gens qui sont
des excellents lecteurs des interprètes
mais la une bonne partie d'entre eux n'a
jamais improvisé du coup ça les bluff
c'est Lucien classique voilà alors que
dans leur partie ils sont formidables
par l'improvisation
comment vous faites pour jouer aussi
bien c'était un renvoi de compliments
ouais parce que ce qui était vrai
[Musique]
après il avait quand même une réputation
chez les musiciens
il était très il était très comme on
appelle ça pas intolérance mais très
exige supra exigeant et il avait des
particules une particularités vraiment
qui était pas évidente à
négocier je dirais à gérer c'est qu'il
est très impatient voilà c'est ça que je
veux dire supra impatient de du coup il
voulait pas tout de suite mais
immédiatement il voulait pas répéter ah
oui il y avait pas de répétition
donc en fait vous arrivez en situation
alors effectivement comme les morceaux
au bout d'un moment on les connaissait
puisqu'on avait les répertoires étaient
souvent le même lui avait une capacité
hallucinante à se réinventer et
improviser uniquement sur les mêmes sur
les mêmes chansons qui faisaient depuis
40 ans sauf qu'en fait on s'ennuyait
jamais parce qu'il avait harmoniquement
il retrouvait toujours y trouver
toujours quelque chose de nouveau ah
ouais vraiment vraiment ça c'est très
bluffant c'était armotiquement il est
incroyable et puis la voix alors il
avait une façon de chanter qu'on
pourrait
beaucoup de gens qui n'aimaient pas oui
mais extrêmement juste oui et puis c'est
il avait une il était malicieux et il
jouait de ce côté
il aimait bien
redevenir un peu un enfant il reste un
enfant c'est quelqu'un qui était comme
ça mais il était très surprenant de je
me rappelle au début je je j'avais pris
à tort la casquette aujourd'hui bon du
batteur
soi-disant solide et je dirais rassurant
et qui un petit peu entre guillemets
pépère quoi et là il est venu voir tout
de suite et dire ah non mais t'as pas
bien compris là c'est pas du tout ça
je veux que tu envoies le quand il y a
l'énergie quand un peu comme un Big Bang
moi-même mais en trio aussi c'est à dire
faut que ça l'étalage des nuances et des
des
interprétations interprétations il faut
qu'il faut que ça soit
voilà vraiment extrêmement marqué marqué
il aime pas le côté il aimait surtout
pas le côté
du coup c'était bien du coup c'était
bien c'était super intéressant
de de
faire l'ouverture du festival de
Juan-les-Pins il y a 97 je crois et du
coup j'en ai passé dehors c'est il y a
la merde
et la mère était derrière donc les gens
avaient le coucher comme ça tous les
grands
et là ils avaient le pari ils avaient
pris le fait le pari de d'inviter donc
le grand avec Jessie Norman d'accord qui
n'avait jamais chanté de sa vie avec un
micro donc là moi j'ai vu j'ai vu j'ai
vécu ça et on voyait bien que c'était la
première fois parce que ils lui ont dit
de tenait madame voilà un micro
était comme ça et elle elle a laissé le
micro comme ça danse
excusez-moi
d'après le micro était comme ça elle
savait pas quoi faire en fait
de l'avoir
il y avait énormément de bruit de fond
et c'était très compliqué
c'est supra sélectionnant quand même la
qualité
la qualité vocale c'est quand même
quelque chose
ah oui c'est énorme dans les grands
souvenirs comme ça de
musiciens avec lesquels vous avez joué
il y a eu avec le grand encore mais
Michel il y a eu il y a eu tout ce style
Mans le l'harmoniciste qui avait un gars
absolument incroyable
mélodie stop vraiment formidable et lui
il était et puis j'ai eu une on a joué
j'ai joué aussi avec
alors un percussionniste qui s'appelle
nana Vasconcellos qui était un Brésilien
qui a joué qui a un CV et à faire pâlir
tous les patricianistes du monde il a
joué avec des musiciens formida et il
avait une personnalité
hors du commun c'était vraiment un type
génial
il lui qui était formidable et puis une
super super musicien américain vibrah
phoniste qui s'appelle Michael
menieri d'accord qui était un gars qui
est un gars pardon
d'une créativité ouais absolument avec
d'une humilité qui est
qu'on a invité pour une tournée en
France il y a une jeune vingtaine
d'années mais qui est venu une façon
extrêmement humble et qui s'est fondé
dans la masse et il a dans la masse au
terme des pas très juste pas très
heureux mais il s'est fondu dans les
adapté
par en dessous et après il a pris il est
reparti sur je dirais pour montrer
toutes ses qualités puis il y a pas très
passionnant vous l'avez fait deux fois
non la comédie musicale Cabaret vous
êtes sur scène absolument avec eux
absolument c'est une expérience
pour un batteur qui est
génial c'est génial on a un petit
extrait on vous voit dans vos œuvres on
va regarder c'est par là
[Musique]
de quelques années
à moi qui s'appelle Gérald massoudbre
qui est un super cadreur et qui m'a et
ouais qui avait invité des amis
collègues à lui pour pour réaliser ça
donc c'est lui qui a fait le montage
j'ai vu parce que je vous ai vu l'autre
jour avec avec le trio Adrian
dont on va parler vous avez une
partition
c'est quoi la partition des battles
le moins possible c'est à dire
par exemple le Big Bang c'est une très
bon
très bon exemple la partition de dans un
Big Bang la partition du batteur c'est
ce qu'on va appeler un squelette
de la de rythmique du morceau alors
toute la structure y est évidemment
comme pour les autres musiciens comme
tous les autres musiciens eux ils ont
des notes bien évidemment le bassiste il
va avoir parfois les notes parfois ce
qu'on appelle les grilles les noms des
accords ce qui lui permettra de de jouer
de d'inventer une ligne de basse une
walking bass comme on dit en anglais
mais c'est une ligne de basse et pour le
batteur on lui met les points d'appui
et le reste en fait c'est une espèce de
canevas dans lequel en fait on a une
liberté totale presque totale avec quand
même des on se retrouve tous sur des
choses alors c'est je trouve ça
passionnant les façons de faire
travailler ces partitions là de Big Bang
dans les cours de danse absolument ou en
fait on peut je vous donne un petit
exemple rigolo c'est qu'en fait il y a
sur le quatrième temps donc ça fait qui
est marqué qui est frais donc ça fait 1
2 3 4
ça tout le monde a compris et en
batterie on nous apprend à faire non pas
ça mais
d'accord à jouer le texte qui anticipe
et c'est que des c'est en fait c'est de
l'anticipation permanente l'une des
complications de la batterie c'est c'est
l'autonomie des mains et des gens non
oui alors c'est le grand
c'est le grand la grande le Grand
Chapitre de ce qu'on appelle
l'indépendance l'indépendance c'est
l'indépendance des des des deux pieds et
des deux mains alors
je dirais que l'indépendance totale des
quatre membres
c'est une illusion ça n'existe pas vrai
c'est pas vrai bon j'ai cassé un peu le
mythe là mais il faut quand même
il y a des instrumentistes qui ont peur
qui sans doute y arriverait bien mieux
que moi d'ailleurs des batteurs qui ont
des techniques absolument faramineuses
et mais les percussionistes là-dessus
voilà qui est d'arriver voilà une
autonomie entre les ce que je veux dire
c'est que on bosse par étape
c'est-à-dire qu'on commence au début on
commence à à latéraliser si on peut dire
le pied droit pour les droitiers le pied
droit et la main droite
et on fait quelque chose au bout d'un
moment
il y a une il y a un entraînement il y a
une mémoire physique il va se créer que
de ça qui fait que ça on a moins besoin
d'y penser donc c'est le début d'une
autonomie voilà
là-dessus on se base pour commencer à
faire autre chose etc c'est passionnant
moi j'adore ce alors on a déjà
un parti mais
un mot vous disiez des grands
qui sont dans votre Panthéon c'est quoi
toute une tripotée des batteurs de jazz
absolument
vous savez qu'il habite il habite pas
loin du tout André l'idée que je salue
qui est un qui est un maître un type
formidable
alors tous les batteurs de jazz faut
hard black et ça c'est un max rose etc
et dans Peter herskin
génial et moi je donnais le nom de John
Bonham le batteur de Led Zeppelin oui
que beaucoup de rockeurs
se réclament et que j'adore j'adore
absolument c'est un j'aime beaucoup
l'avoir les deux les
il faut qu'on dise un mot de Adrien
avec on va dire ouais pardon
argenterie et Sandrine connerie
qui chanteuse qui est organismes je vous
ai vu récemment dans un spectacle sur
Nougaro et oui ça c'est assez formidable
mais oui voilà il y a des bah c'est déjà
un trio qui soit qui d'où quelques
années je crois c'est ça voilà on a fait
l'ouverture de la de saison du prisme à
Élancourt du coup c'était avec avec vous
on s'est on était ravi de c'est comme ça
qu'on s'est rencontré absolument et avec
Thomas perron qui qui dirige qui est
directeur du théâtre et du coup c'est
une chouette
ce trio là c'est une très belle aventure
on a on est on a commencé cette aventure
j'essaie de faire court un peu de en
notre le
notre amour qui nous réunit c'est
l'amour de la mélodie c'est ça le le la
base de de notre de notre passion de ça
après on a chacun notre
et nos aptitudes
aller faire vivre Damien c'est le
l'éminance grise c'est lui il a trois
cerveaux en même temps il a il est le
bassiste de la main gauche il est le
pianiste de la main droite et et qu'on
soit les arrangements
[Musique]
Sandrine elle arrive elle a une
exceptionnelle
un vrai semblable c'est-à-dire qu'elle
elle vient du elle vient du gospel elle
a fait elle a fait beaucoup de musique
du monde elle chante en turc en
macédonien en russe en slave en bulgare
puisqu'elle a été elles ont elle fait
partie d'un trio puis elles ont été
sollicités par Stromae pour le pour la
loi
dans la chanson l'enfer en fait les
trois voies c'est son tel
leur trio orenda donc elles ont elles
ont un rayon d'action super large en
fait Sandrine et puis là alors vous avez
mais moi
et ça correspond exactement à ce qui est
passionnant avec Nougaro c'est ça a été
de de reprendre en fait on on avait déjà
commencé à avoir déjà un son en trio
depuis quelques temps ça commençait à
être existé vraiment ça et un ami à nous
nous a dit tiens on fait un on fait un
spécial Nougaro ce dans un mois ce que
c'est est-ce que est-ce que ça vous
dirait alors évidemment le challenge
c'était de
oui vous serez le 8 juillet au planche à
Coignières oui un quartet très
rapidement vite vite vite vite c'est un
quartet avec des musiciens de de des
amis de très longue date d'accord
plutôt jazz fusion funk etc on va on va
bien s'amuser vous serez le toujours à
Coignières mais l'Espace 2D le 13
octobre c'est un vendredi 13 octobre
le nouveau le nouveau ça porte bonheur
évidemment le nouveau projet d'Adrien
Clark d'accord le nouveau le nouveau
spectacle voilà création et 2 février en
2024 à la batterie à Guyancourt
absolument
c'est le samedi 3 je crois que je me
c'est moi 3 février
3 février samedi 3 à la batterie de
Guyancourt un projet sur le même la
création qu'on aura fait en octobre
en fait sur de lait sur la pop anglaise
en fait comme on a pris Nougaro là on
prend la alors la pop anglaise il y a
c'est même pas un boulevard c'est c'est
3 avenue tellement il y a des il y a une
source d'inspiration incroyable
merci beaucoup David merci beaucoup
Patrice merci merci et bonne batterie
[Musique]